ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROUGH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BROUGH. BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON MISSED GRAYSON.
PLEASE JOIN IN PRAYER. DOT OF
ALL WHOSE MERCY IS EVERLASTING
TO EVERLASTING AND HIS GRACE IS
SUFFICIENT EVEN IN THE MOST
TRYING OF TIMES AND WHO IS OUR
PRESENT HELP IN TROUBLED TIMES
MAKE YOUR PRESENCE KNOWN AND
HERE ARE CRY SO THAT WHEN OUR
HEARTS OR OVERWHELMED WE CAN
FIND SOLIS IN YOUR PROTECTING
HAND. STRENGTH THAT WE MAY
UNDER PROVISION PROVISION THAT
NEEDS MAYBE MATT. PLEASE FOR
THE SAKE OF CALM AND STABILITY
PROTECTION FOR THE VULNERABLE
HEALING FOR THE SICK AND ABOVE
ALL RENDER YOUR SPIRIT OF LOVE.
ALL TO FIND COMFORT IN. WE HOLD
TO YOUR WORD THAT YOU WILL
NEVER LEAVE NO FOR SAKE AND
THAT YOU ARE FAITHFUL AND JUST.
SHINE YOUR LIGHT IN A WAY THAT
THE EDGES THE DARK CLOUDS
CURRENTLY OVER US. MAY LIST.
THESE OF. IT MAY COME IN THE
MORNING READ YOUR BREATH OF
LIFE UPON US THAT WE MAY SEE IN
THIS PRESENT CRISIS YOUR SEPT
INNING POWER GIVE US THE
KNOWLEDGE NEEDED TO FACE WHAT
IS BEFORE US WISDOM BY GUIDANCE
AND THE COMPASSION TO ENCOURAGE
AND LIFT THE SPIRITS OF THOSE
MOST IN NEED LET ALL GLORY
HONOR AND PRAISE BELONG TO YOU
MAN. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN
US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER GALLAGHER. SALUTE I HIS
LACK OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO. ST STE. ISRAEL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE AM I WILL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THIS AND THE
PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK SUE
PARKER AT THE DESK READING FOR
KATHLEEN AND LOUIS READING THE
ROLES CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT SURE BONTA
MOVES. AND MR LACKEY SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY CALL RIGHTLY MON
WALDRON IN BOERER HORVATH TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB
ONE NINE EIGHT NINE CRISTINA
GARCIA FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE KILEY FROM THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND AB
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT DOT OFTEN
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MISTER CELIS I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A FEW GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY MR SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND BRAVE THE
ELEMENTS TO BE WITH US. TODAY
THEY REPRESENT EIGHT OF THE
COUNTIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THE BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA
pPLEASE WELCOME THEM TO THE
FLOOR THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW RECESS FOR DEMOCRATIC
AND REPUBLICAN CAUCUSES.
REPUBLICANS REPORT TO THE
MEMBERS LOUNGE DEMOCRATS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MUST REPORT
TO ROOM FORTY TWO. OH TWO
MEMBERS ARE NOT PERMITTED TO
RETURN TO THEIR OFFICES.
DEMOCRATS IN ROOM FORTY TWO A
TWO REPUBLICANS IN THE MEMBERS
LOUNGE.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE'RE
BACK IN SESSION PLEASE REPORT
TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE
ARE BACK IN SESSION.
MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MILLION BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MISTER BONTA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
WITHDRAW SB EIGHTY NINE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND SB ONE SEVENTEEN
REVIEW FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING TO TAKE THESE BILLS
UP TODAY WITHOUT. PRINCE TO
FILE. WITHOUT ACTION. MISTER
BARTEL YOUR GET RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER THERE IS A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK TO
DISPENSE WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL THREE READINGS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION. RESOLVED THAT
SENATE BILLS NUMBERS EIGHTY
NINE AND 117% A CASE OF URGENCY
AS THAT TERM IS USED IN ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHTY ONE OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE PROVISION
OF THAT ACCORDING TO THE BILL
BE READ ON THREE SEPARATE DAYS
IN EACH HOUSES BY DISPENSED
WITH AND IS ORDER BUILT PLATE
UPON THEIR PASSAGE AND
CONSIDERED A- MEMBERS. TWO
THIRDS VOTE TO DISPENSE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL THREE READINGS
REQUIREMENT THIS IS NOT
DEBATABLE TO TWO THIRDS
THRESHOLD. OR CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MISTER BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SHE WANTS AS FOR
NIVEAU FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
RESTAURANT IS ASKING FOR A VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THE CLERK
WILL READ THE BILL'S A SECOND
TIME. SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE
AND ONE SEVENTEEN. MEMBERS A
STATEMENT FROM THE GOVERNOR IS
APT THE DESK RELATIVE TO THE
NECESSITY FOR DISPENSING WITH
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE
PERIOD FOR BILLS. THE STATEMENT
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MR BONTA YOU
ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK TO DISPENSE WITH THE
SEVENTY SEVENTY TWO HOUR
PUBLISHING REQUIREMENTS ON
SPECIFIC BILLS I ASK THAT WE GO
TO THAT I AM NOW. LUCIEN
RESOLVED THAT SENATE BILLS
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE AND ONE
SEVENTY CENTS 17% CASE URGENCY
AS THAT TERM IS USED IN ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION AB TWO OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND PREDICTIONS OF
THAT SECTION CRYING THAT BILLS
WITH ANY AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
PRINTED TO GET TO MEMBERS AND
PUBLIC ENTERED THE FINAL FORM
AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO HOURS
BEFORE THAT IS HERE AND WITH.
THE PASSAGE REQUIREMENT. IS NOT
DEBATABLE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. CERVANTES ASKING FOR
AN IPHONE. THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR MISTER BONTA IS ASKING FOR
NINE. MR BONTA. AS FOR NINE.
THE CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY NINE.
KERKORIAN SENATE BILL EIGHTY
NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AND EXPLAIN
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MISTER KING YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS WE
ARE IN VERY CHALLENGING TIMES
AS WE FACE THIS CORONA VIRUS
PAN DOWN IN OUR STATE. WE ARE
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
APPROPRIATE. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO GIVE THE
GOVERNOR BROUGHT A FORTY TO
DEAL WITH THIS PANDEMIC IN OUR
STATE. CIVIC LEAVE THIS
APPROPRIATION MENTIONS GIVEN
THE GOVERNOR THE ABILITY TO
INCREASE HOSPITAL CAPACITY
INCREASE BED CAPACITY FOR
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AROUND
OUR STATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE HOTELS AND MOTELS TO
GET PEOPLE OUR STREETS AND THEN
LASTLY INSURING THERE'S MONEY
FOR EXTRA CLEANING CHILD CARE.
OF OUR STATE. THE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SPLIT UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS ONCE JAIL BC
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN NOTIFIED WE
THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THE GOVERNOR THE TOOL. TO
FIGHT THIS PANDEMIC IN OUR
STATE. WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON THIS DISASTER IF.
THERE ARE ANY. LOSING THEIR
JOBS GETTING THEIR HOURS CUT
LOSING THEIR ABILITY TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE PAY RENT WE
ALSO KNOW THERE MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ON THE
BRINK. OF CLOSE. SO WE PUT IT
IN LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE EVERY
INTENT TO. DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE- WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGE THAT
WAS PASSED WITH A TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT STIMULUS REALLY
MEANS FOR OUR STATE HEARING
CALIFORNIA. BUT ALSO SPENT TIME
TO FIGURE OUT HOW US. COULD
ASSIST ALL OUR CONSTITUENTS UP
A DOWN THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
STAYING MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY NINE THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE GOVERNOR TO
APPROPRIATE UP TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND MONEY
TO DEAL WITH. AND PRESS OF OUR-
THE SHORT CUTS THE USUAL
CREATION OF BUDGETARY PROCESSES
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
INSTEAD ONLY REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO NOTIFY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SEVENTY TWO OUT OF
SPENDING THOSE FUNDS. BY TAKING
THIS ACTION WE ARE PLACING AN
EXTRAORDINARY DEGREE OF TRUST
IN GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
HOWEVER THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES AND IT MAKES SENSE TO
CONCENTRATE DECISION. AUTHORITY
THE PLACE WERE THE- THE SECOND
BEST EXPEDITE GETTING THESE
FUNDS TO THE VIAL USES IT'LL
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF THIS
ILLNESS. THESE FUNDS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS BUILT UP
TO DEAL WITH HIS EMERGENCY TO
MITIGATING DAMAGE TO BURKE BUT
BOY IMPACT WAY. SURE THAT MY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STUPID IRISH
AND I. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE MISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT TODAY
AT A MOMENT WITHOUT PRECEDENT
IN ANY OF OUR EXPERIENCE FOR
NEARLY FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THREE AND THIRTY
MILLION AMERICANS AND PEOPLE
ALL AROUND THE WORLD. THIS IS
THE REAL TIME A SHARP AND BREAK
FROM ALL NORMALCY IT'S A MOMENT
OF CRISIS IN EVERY SENSE OCIAL
PARALYSIS. I'M A BALL AND
MORTAL PAIR. IT'S A MOMENT
WHERE THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CITIZENS AND GOVERNMENT HAS
BECOME A RADICALLY DIFFERENT.
THE MOST TRIFLING IS A PERSONAL
CONCERN WHERE TO EAT LUNCH WHO
TO VISIT HOW TO SPEND THE
WEEKEND ARE NOW WITHIN THE
AMBIT OF STATE POLICY AND
ULTIMATELY STATE POWER. FOR
THAT REASON. RELATIONSHIP OF
TRUST OPENNESS DIALOGUE AND
ACCESSIBILITY BETWEEN
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES. HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE IMPORTANT. TODAY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE SB
EIGHTY NINE AND I'M SUPPORTING
OUR GOVERNOR. I STAND READY TO
ASSIST GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITIES
ANYWAY I CAN I CALL IN EVERY
LEGISLATOR AND CAL. ARE LESS OF
POLITICAL PRINCE TO TRUST IN
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SHIP AND
LISTEN TO HIS GUIDANCE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT HARSH
DISRUPTIVE PREVIOUSLY
UNTHINKABLE RESTRICTION. MATTER
NOT A CHOICE BUT A NECESSITY.
WE SHOULD ALL OFFER OUR OWN
IDEAS EVEN CRITICISM WHERE
APPROPRIATE BUT ONLY AS PART OF
A COLLABORATIVE SEARCH FOR
SOLUTIONS THE PARTISAN RITUALS
OF ORDINARY POLITICS HAVE NO
PLACE IN THESE EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES. WE SHOULD ALSO ASK. IN
THE MIDST OF SWEEPING EXECUTIVE
ACTION. WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY EVEN IF WE'RE
AWAY FROM THE CAPITAL. BEYOND
THE NOT BOLTS OF APPROPRIATING
AND AUTHORIZING AS WE'RE DOING
NOW. WE CAN OFFER SOMETHING
MORE. PERSPECTIVE INSIDE AND
FEEDBACK. AS THE GOVERNOR IS
IMMERSED IN THE URGENT AND ALL
CONSUMING TASKS OF CONFRONTING
DEREK. WE CAN TAKE A SOMEWHAT
BROADER VIEW. THIS INCLUDES
ANTICIPATING THE SECONDARY AND
TERTIARY PROBLEMS THAT WILL
INEVITABLY ARISE FROM FAR
REACHING INTERVENTION SOME OF
WHICH WERE MENTIONED BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. PLEASE PUT OUR
IMMEDIATE AND URGENT KIDS WHO
ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AND MISSING
MEALS. OTHERS ARE JUST AS CLEAR
BUT CUMULATIVE A LOSS OF
LEARNING TIME FOR STUDENTS OF
INCOME FOR WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES OF SERVICES FROM
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. OTHER
CORROSIVE EFFECTS ARE MORE
SUBTLE THE PSYCHOLOGICAL TOLL
OF ISOLATION THE DEPLETION OF
SOCIAL CAPITAL THE STRAIN
FABRIC OF COMMUNITIES RIVEN BY
FEAR THESE ARE UNFAMILIAR
VEXING MONUMENTAL CHALLENGES
THEY CRIED OUT FOR LEGISLATIVE
ATTENTION AND WISDOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE WORKING WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS IS CONSUMER. WE'RE
IN THIS TOGETHER AND THE WAY
WILL MEET THESE CHALLENGES IS
TOGETHER WITH INGENUITY AND
RESOURCEFULNESS WITH GOOD WILL
AND COMPASSION WITH STRENGTH
AND SOLIDARITY. SOCIAL DISTANCE
NEED NOT MEAN SOCIETAL
DISSONANCE OR SPIRITUAL DISCORD.
IN A WAY THE VERY INTER
CONNECTEDNESS THAT MADE THIS
VIRUS SO QUICK TO SPREAD ALSO
GIVES US THE CAPACITY. TO
DEFEAT IT. AND WE HAVE ANOTHER
ADVANTAGE I CAN DO SENSE OF
POSSIBILITY THAT IS DISTINCTLY
CALIFORNIA. AN UNMATCHED
ABILITY TO TAKE OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MAKE THE BEST
OF THEM. THAT'S WHAT WE MUST
NOW MORE THAN EVER WHETHER WE
CAN A RISE TO THE OCCASION IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD WILL
DETERMINE THE FATE OF UNTOLD
LIVES AND WILL SHAPE WHAT OUR
STATE LOOKS LIKE ON THE UPPER
SIDE. ASK FOR ALL THE BILL YES
HONEST. THANK YOU MISS KILEY
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. WHICH TEN YOU MAY
CLOSE YOUR WISH. MEMBERS
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF OUT. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN
COOPERATE. SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY THE EDUCATION FINANCE
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATE TO THE BUDGET MR CHANEY
MAKE AN OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB ONE SEVENTEEN. IT IS
URGENT ACTION TO ENSURE THAT
OUR SCHOOLS WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO FUNCTION. AS A
PUBLIC SCHOOL- WHOSE DAUGHTERS
ARE HOME THIS WEEK LIKE OVER
FIFTY ONE PERCENT. OF THE
SCHOOLS ACROSS OUR STATE IN
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION OTHER
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE STE. SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED AND
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE
WHEN OUR STUDENTS GET BACK TO
SCHOOL. SO SB ONE SEVENTEEN
INSURERS THAT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS ARE HELD
HARMLESS DURING THIS TIME. IT
ALSO WISHERS ALL THE CHARTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE HELD
HARMLESS AT THIS POINT IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
OPTIONS IT ALSO WAVES
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTE
REQUIREMENTS FREE DISK HAS TO
RECALL THAT'S- ALL STOP.
COMPLAINT TIME IT'S BEEN BUDGET
CATION TIME. THE LAST. ADDITION
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOL CAN
ACTUALLY CLEAN THEMSELVES
DURING THIS VERY. SPENT TIME
WITH VIRUS PANDEMIC DID YOU OF
A PUBLIC HER TEACHERS DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR WIPES OR
FOR DISINFECTANTS THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THAT REACHES EVERY SINGLE
CLASSROOM. TO THEM EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO CALL THEMSELVES
OUR STUDENTS TO RETURN TO THE
CLASSROOM WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY FOR A VOTE ON SB
AND SEVENTEEN. THANKS FOR
STAYING MISTER OBERNOLTE
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE SEVENTEEN THE FUNDING
CHANGES THAT THIS BILL MAKES
ARE CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHETHER THIS
UNPRECEDENTED EMERGENCY. ALSO
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S APPROPRIATED FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. FOR THE PURPOSES
OF CLEANING SCHOOL SITES IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO MAKING
SURE THIS VIRUS DOESN'T IT
FURTHER I REGION I'VE- THANK
YOU SHARON AWFULLY. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. THE CLUB OF ROLL
CALL MEMBERS. DESERT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE. QUIRK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SEVEN. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE ASSEMBLY SECOND
RATING OPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FORTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS TWO
THREE AND FOUR ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX ACR ONE EIGHTY TWO BY MR
LACKEY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS. THIS LACKEY
YOU MAY OPEN. WELL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ON A MORE
POSITIVE NOTE. A MINOR TODAY TO
PRESENT TO SAY SEE ARTS ONE
EIGHTY TWO WHICH PROCLAIMS
MARCH FIFTEENTH TO MARCH TWENTY
SECOND AS CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS WEEK. IT
ALSO DECLARES MARCH TWENTY
FIRST SINCE CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME DAY. DOES SANDRA WAS A
CHROMOSOMAL DISORDER THAT
OCCURS IN ABOUT ONE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND BIRTHS.
OUT OF THE ACCESS TO CARE.
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
INCLUSIVE EDUCATION AND
APPROPRIATE RESEARCHER VITAL TO
THE GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
INJURED INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
SYNDROME MAKE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS IMPORTANT WE
RECOGNIZE THEIR INHERENT
DIGNITY AND WORTH. MEMBERS I
ASK THAT YOU ALL STAND WITH ME
AND PROJECT OUR GRATITUDE TO A
COMMUNITY THAT IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED I JUST WANT TO
MENTION. MANY OF YOU MAY NOT BE
AWARE OF THE FACT. THAT
RECENTLY WE HAD A DOWN SYNDROME.-LAWYER WHO WORKED DOWN IN THE
GIFT SHOP. WHO WORKED IN THIS
INSTITUTION FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. AND HER NAME WAS JENNY
AND- I HOPE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET HER
BECAUSE- SHE HAD A LOT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS INSTITUTION
AND OF THESE PEOPLE I CAN
PROMISE YOU THAT THERE IS A LOT
TO LEARN FROM THEM AND THEY'LL
MAKE YOU BETTER PEOPLE IF YOU
GIVE THEM A CHANCE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO- ASKING FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY MR GRAYSON YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A PROUD
JOINT AUTHOR OF ACR ONE EIGHTY
TWO. HONORING CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS DAY AND
WEEK. DESPITE ARE CHROMOSOMAL
DIFFERENCES. INDIVIDUALS ARE
DOWN SYNDROME ATTEND SCHOOL
WORK. PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS
THAT AFFECT THEM HAVE
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS VOTE
AND CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY IN
MANY WONDERFUL WAYS. HERE JUST
A FEW EXAMPLES OF THE
PROFESSIONAL SUCCESSES IN THE
LAST DECADE. IN GAFFNEY HAS
EARNED RECOGNITION FOR HER
DISTANCE SWIMMING. AND WAS THE
FIRST PERSON WITH DOWN SYNDROME
TO COMPLETE A RELAY SWIM OF THE
ENGLISH CHANNEL. SHE IS ALSO
THE PRESENCE OF OUR OWN
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION RAISING
AWARENESS AND PROMOTING
INCLUSION THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES. FOR HER WORK SHE
RECEIVED AN HONORARY DOCTORATE
DEGREE. THE UNIVERSITY. ONE N.
PAINTER AS AN ARTIST WITH THE
UNIQUE AND EXPRESSIVE STYLE HER
ARTWORK HAS BEEN EXHIBITED IN
NUMEROUS ART GALLERIES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
LAST BUT DEFINITELY NOT LEAST
TIM HARRIS BECAME THE OWNER OF
HIS OWN RESTAURANT. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE WAS
CERTIFICATES IN FOOD SERVICES
OFFICE SKILLS AND RESTAURANT
HOSTING HE ALSO STARTED A
FOUNDATION TO HELP OTHERS WITH
DISABILITIES START THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES. FOR AT LEAST THANK
YOU FOR IT ATTENTION AND
RECOGNITION OF THE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DOWN SYNDROME MAKE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A C. R. ONE EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISTER
LACKEYS ACTION OF THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RISEN
GENESIS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL REMAINS
IN PLACE THE QUORUM CALL
REMAINS IN PLACE WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. WE ASK THAT YOU GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE TURNING
IN THE MEMORY. AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A
GERMAN A MEMORY. HELLO. LONG
TIME DAVE DAVIS RESIDENT AND
MASTER GUITARIST CHARLES LITTLE
CHARLIE ABOUT THE TAKE KNOWN
WORLDWIDE AS A MASTERS A BLUES
GUITARIST DIED ON MARCH SIX
TWENTY TWENTY OF A HEART ATTACK
AT THE AGE OF SIXTY SIX. BODY
IS BEST FOR THE LEADER OF THE
WARD WINNING BLUES LITTLE BAND
THE BAND LITTLE CHARLIE AND THE
NIGHT CATS WHO RELEASED NINE
ALBUMS ON ALLIGATOR RECORDS
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS FORTY
YEAR CAREER CHARLIE SHARED
STAGES WITH MUDDY WATERS GREGG
ALLMAN. ROBERT CRAY ALBERT
COLLINS LOS LOBOS MANY OTHERS
DURING THE NINETEEN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN TOUR WITH JOHN LEE
HOOKER THE BLUES LEGEND TOLD
ABOUT IT. YOUR DANGEROUS WITH
THAT GUITAR MAN YOU GOT TO PUT
YOU IN JAIL. BETTY WAS BORN IN
BIRMINGHAM ALABAMA MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND EARLY AGE HE FELL
IN LOVE WITH LOSES A CHILD WAS
PLAYING HER MONICA BY THE AGE
OF TWELVE. THE DEGREE IN THE
MAX FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. WELL
CHARLIE BEGAN HIS MUSICAL
CAREER IN THE MID NINETEEN
SIXTIES AS A HARMONICA PLAYER
AND VOCALIST TUNING THE GUITAR
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES
HE MOVED TO SUCK FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE SEARCH UP A REAL
BILL JOY BOB. SOON FOR MARK A
PLAYER AND THE THOUGHT RIGHT
RIGHT RICK IN. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THE FORM BILL CHARLIE IN
ACCOUNTS QUICKLY BECOMING ONE
OF THE MOST TALKED ABOUT IS BIG
ON THE LOCAL SCENE THE TO. THE
WORD NOT. STOP A BABY TYPE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. THE RELEASE FOR
TOTAL ARE ALBUMS AND LIFE AND
HIS MOST RECENT WAS SCHOOL TALK
INTO THE SEVEN. CHARLIE WAS
OFTEN DESCRIBED AS A MUSICAL
FORCE OF NATURE WITH IS UNIQUE
AND FEARLESS GUITAR PLAYING
HAVING INCLUDES FLUENCY
COUNTLESS YOUNG BLUES GUITARIST
WHO WILL IN NO DOUBT KEEP HIS
MEMORY IN STYLE ALIVE FOR YEARS.
IDEAS SOME OF US SURVIVED BY
HIS SISTERS CATHERINE IN LAUREL
AND MOTHER IN LAW MARY MONTERO
HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY A
SISTER AND HIS WIFE SYLVIA. I
ASKED YOU JOIN ME IN
REMEMBERING THE LIFE OF A
UNIQUE TALENT OF LITTLE CHARLIE
BATY. THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY.
MISTER KALRA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I HAVE THE
HONOR OF ASKING THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF FORMER
SAN JOSE MAYOR. SUSAN HAMMER.
SUSAN HAMMER WAS THE SIXTY
SECOND MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE. SHE WAS ELECTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY. AND THEN
SERVED TWO FOUR YEAR TERMS
NINETY ONE UNTIL NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. SHE WAS KNOWN FOR
INCLUSIVENESS IN EQUITY. YOUTH
AND EDUCATION ARTS AND CULTURE
THE ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SUSAN'S IMPACT
CONTINUES TO BE FELT IN SAN
JOSE TO THIS DAY. PRIOR TO
SERVING AS MAYOR. SUSAN HAMMER
SERVE AS A SAN JOSE CITY
COUNCIL REPRESENTING DISTRICT
THREE FROM. NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE TO NINETEEN NINETY. SHE
WAS BORN AND ALTADENA
CALIFORNIA. ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY AND LATER MARRIED
PHILIP HAMMER. THEY HAD THREE
CHILDREN AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN.
SUSAN WAS DYING DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IN HER
LATER YEARS AND IT PROGRESS
RAPIDLY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS OF HER LIFE LEADING HER
PASSING ON MARCH SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. SHE PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY ONE.
SEASON LEAVES A LEGACY IN
PUBLIC SERVICE PERCENT JOSE.
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP SHE
SECURED REDEVELOPMENT FUNDING
FOR UNDERSERVED NEIGHBORHOODS
IN CRITICAL SOCIAL SERVICES A
TRAILBLAZING MOVE THAT HELPED
PAVE ROADS AND PICKS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN SOME OF SAN
JOSE'S NEEDIEST AREAS. SHE ALSO
SPEARHEADED THOUSANDS EFFORTS
TO HIRE AN APPOINT PEOPLE OF
COLOR MAKING DIVERSITY A
CORNERSTONE OF HER LEGACY. SHE
HIRED THE CITY'S FIRST AFTER
AMERICAN CITY MANAGER REGINA
WILLIAMS IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. SOME OF HER MANY NOTABLE
ACHIEVEMENTS INCLUDE CREATING
PROJECT DIVERSITY. THE SOUNDS A
CONSERVATION CORPS YOUTH
HOMEWORK CENTERS CITY YEAR AND
SAN JOSE THE MAYOR'S GANG TASK
FORCE AND MAYORS GREEN LINE
INITIATIVE. BUILDING OF THE
MEXICAN HERITAGE PLAZA THE SAN
JOSE REPERTORY THEATRE. THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING LIBRARY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SOUNDS A STATE
UNIVERSITY AS WELL AS THE SHARK
TANK THE SAN JOSE ARENA. SHE
ALSO BROUGHT CISCO AND ADOBE
GLOBAL HEADQUARTERS TO SAN JOSE
CEMENTING SAN JOSE AS THE
CAPITAL OF SILICON VALLEY AND
IT'S URBAN CORE. SUSAN IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND PHILLIP
AND HER THREE CHILDREN BOW
HALLIE AND MATT AS WELL AS HER
SIX GRANDCHILDREN AND I WANT TO
PERSONALLY- OFFER MY
CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF OF OUR
ENTIRE. ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS
CONSTITUENTS OF DISTRICT TWENTY
SEVEN I HAD THE GREAT PLEASURE
OF GETTING TO KNOW SUSAN EVEN
PRIOR TO MY LIFE IN ELECTED
OFFICE SHE WAS ALWAYS AN
INCREDIBLE MENTOR. HUMBLE YET
FIRM IN HER BELIEVES IN BUT
PUBLIC SERVICE CAN MEAN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND FOR THAT I'LL BE
FOREVER GRATEFUL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF SUSAN
HAMMER THANK YOU. FAMOUS KALRA
N. MISTER CHIU PANTS INSURE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS IS
GERMAN A MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKERS AND- MEMBERS- I
HAVE KNOWN A MAYOR HAMMER FOR
OVER TWENTY SOME YEARS I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE ONE OF THE
SCHOOL THE STORY JUSTICE- POP
UP ON MY MIND WHEN WERE YOU
THINKING ABOUT. THE A MISTER
OF- SO HAMMER THE BILE WHEN SHE
WAS THE MAYOR AT THE SET THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE ALL OF MY WIFE
AND I OPERATE IT A CHINESE
RESTAURANT I REMEMBER ONE DAY
THERE'S A NUMBER PROFIT GREW
YOU KNOW A FRIEND'S SICKLY.
CALLING US TO SAY HEY YOU HAVE
TO THE SAVE THAT THEY- OF FALL
FALL US YOU HAVE TO- CANCEL ALL
THE RESERVATION. OF BECAUSE WE
WANT YOUR RESTAURANT BE CLOSE
FOR A PRIVATE PARTY ARE BEING
FULL PUT THEIR NUMBER. IT WAS
WHAT WHAT THIS IS THE URGENCY
OF THE AND THE AND TWO WAS
STATUTES HAMMER WAS INVITED
ASKED THEIR GUEST. AS A MATTER
OF TIME I'LL. SAY SO ONE NOT
GOOD. ALSO I OF SANTA. FOR A
LARGE OF. THE LIST OF THE VERY
SAME RAT. IS SO. THEY DO HAVE
TO. THEIR VAN THE OLD BOOK ALL
ADULTS SAVED HAVE TO FOR A
VENUE AND TO ME THE- TO SAY WHO.
SO YOU KNOW THE SHE'D BRING YOU
THE HOW THE SAN JOSE IN. REALLY
REALLY HELPED THIS SMALL
BUSINESS IN SAN JOSE SHE
REALLY. LOVES US SAN JOSE AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY AND THE SHE
WAS SOUL LOVE AND RESPECT
RESPECTED BY THE SAN JOSE
PEOPLE. BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW OF
ANY OTHER YOU LUCK THAT
OFFICIAL WHEN THE- THE TURNED.
THE INVITATION TO GO ALSO HELP
THEIR JURISDICTION AND THE
ORGANIZATION WILL CHANGE THAT.
THE VENUE FOR THIS ELECTED
OFFICER TO I TRY MY CELL THIS
FOR IT WILL. GOODBYE ANOTHER
SPEAKER AND YOU KNOW IN THE END
YOU EARN. YOU YOU HAVE TO BE A
THREE THE GAS THURS. THAT SAVES
A LOT OF AS WHOSE NAME THERE
ARE REMEMBER SAYING. THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBER Là M<c.cyan> WHO ARE</c>
RECKONED FOR GERMAN MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER. I RISE TO
JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF MY QUE
HOSTS WHO PASSED AWAY ON THE
EVENING OF FEBRUARY SEVEN
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS HE DIED THE SAME WAY HE
LIVED WITH GRACE AND DEDICATION
TO HIS FAMILY FRIENDS AND
CHURCH. MIGHT PAY HOST WAS BORN
IN PENNSYLVANIA IN AUGUST THIRD
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE TO GREEK
IMMIGRANTS THE HARRIS AND MERRY
PAY HOST. IN HIGH SCHOOL MIKE
FOCUSED ON FUN HE PLAYED
FOOTBALL AND WAS A HIGHLY
REGARDED DANCER. IN HIS TEENS
MIKE TAUGHT HIMSELF HOW TO PLAY
THE PIANO AND OFTEN PLAYED IN
CHICAGO'S NEIGHBORHOOD BARS.
DURING THE KOREAN WAR MIKE WAS
DRAFTED BUT SPENT HIS ENTIRE
MILITARY TOUR IN GERMANY MILES
AWAY FROM THE WAR THAT RAGE ON.
THE AT REYES ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA AFTER THE WAR MIKE
WORKED AT A FAMILY DINER AUTO
BODY MANUFACTURING PLANTS AND
EVENTUALLY ROLLED AT UCLA LATER
TRANSFERRED TO BERKELEY WHERE
HE EARNED A DEGREE AS A LINK
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT WHILE IN
BERKELEY HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS
LIFE VIVIAN AN AIRLINE
STEWARDESS FOR PAN AM WHO ALSO
CAME FROM GREEK LINEAGE. AFTER
SHORT COURTSHIP THEY MARRIED
AND VIVIAN SUPPORTED. HER THEN
STUDENT HUSBAND AND THEN MOVED
TO TAKE A LEAD IN NINETEEN
SIXTY. IT WAS THERE THAT MIKE
BEGAN A LONG CAREER AS A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR PARKS IN OUR
DISTRICT SERVING AS BOTH THE
CITY OF SANTA BARBARA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY PARKS DIRECTOR.
HIS LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS
EXTENSIVE. MIKE PUSHED FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF LAND THAT WOULD
BECOME SHORELINE PARK AND
INSTALL THE VOLLEYBALL NET AT
THE SPEED. THAT HELP MAKE THE
SPORT POPULAR WITH LOCALS. HE
ACQUIRED LAKE LOS CARNEROS AND
EXTENDED THE PURE ACTUALLY TO
BEACH. HE HELP SAVE THE LOW
BARROW THEATER WHICH WOULD BE
SOLD BECAUSE THE COUNTY CANNOT
AFFORD THE REQUIRED UPGRADE.
HIS FINAL PUBLISHED AN WAS THE
PURCHASE OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY ACRES OF GALENA
COASTLINE KNOWN AS SANTA
BARBARA SHORES. WHICH IS VERY
POPULAR FOR ITS MANY HIKING
TRAILS AND BUTTERFLY PRESERVE.
MIKE PAY JOSE WAS ALSO
DEDICATED TO THE GREEK ORTHODOX
COMMUNITY AND IS REGARDED AS A
PILLAR OF THE COMMUNITY AND THE
GODFATHER OF OUR LOCAL GREEK
FESTIVAL. MIKE WAS A TALENTED
AND DEDICATED SERVANT TO HIS
CHURCH AND COMMUNITY ALL WHILE
BEING A LOVING HUSBAND FATHER
AND LOVING HIS GRANDCHILDREN.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
SIXTY ONE YEARS VDM PAY HOST.
DAUGHTER MARIA PAY HOST BENTSEN
SENT THE PAY HOST SON IN LAW
BRUCE BENSON DAUGHTER IN LAW
LEORA PAY HER AND GRAY CHILDREN
MARIE AND VIVIAN. HE LOVED HE'S
SAYING HE DANCED AND HE MADE
LIFE BETTER FOR ALL OF US
WHETHER YOU KNEW HIM OR NOT.
THE SANTA BARBARA THAT WE KNOW
WAS IN RICH BY HIM MIKE WAS NOT
THE LUCKIEST MAN ALIVE AS HE
DESCRIBED MOMENTS BEFORE HIS
PASSING HE EARNED HIS GOOD
FORTUNE SANTA BARBARA WAS LUCKY
TO HAVE HIM IN OUR LIVES. THANK
YOU MISS EMMA MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARISE TASKS
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
ESCONDIDO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
JOHN MASSON. JOHN WAS APPOINTED
TO THE CITY COUNCIL IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN FACT HE
FILLED MY SEAT WHEN I WAS
ELECTED TO THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND HE- WAS REELECTED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND REELECTED AGAIN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. HE SERVED AS
DEPUTY MAYOR IS THE CITY'S
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY AS AS
CAN BE DOES REPRESENTATIVE ON
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES. THE MAYOR'S ECONOMIC
ADVISORY BOARD AND THE CITY'S
GENERAL PLAN UPDATE COMMITTEE.
JOHN WAS PRESIDENT OF HIS
FAMILY ON CIVIL ENGINEERING AND
SURVEYING COMPANY MASSON AND
ASSOCIATES AND WAS A MEMBER OF
THE NORTH COUNTY CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND LAND SURVEYORS AS
WELL AS THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. HE WAS A PRODUCT
OF ESCONDIDO HE ATTENDANT
CONLEE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL GRANT
MIDDLE SCHOOL NOW MISSION
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND WAS A%
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ESCONDIDO
HIGH GRADUATE. AS A FRIEND HE
WORKED TIRELESSLY FOR HIS CITY
FOR ALL THE YEARS THAT I KNEW
HIM. HE HAD A PASSION FOR
ESCONDIDO AND PUT HIS ALL INTO
TRYING TO MAKE IT A BETTER
PLACE TO LIVE. JOHN WAS A MAN
OF DEEP FAITH A LOVING HUSBAND
TO HIS WIFE TRICIA. AND THE
FATHER TO HIS TWO CHILDREN
NICHOLAS AND TEARING. HE WILL
BE SORELY MISSED BY ALL WHO
KNEW AND LOVED HIM. AND BY THE
PEOPLE OF THE CITY HE LOVED AND
SERVE. I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS WALDRON. AND MISS
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RECOGNIZED
YES I ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASISTIR
INJURED IN THE MEMORY OF FORMER
COUNCIL MEMBER- JOHN MASS AND
JOHN MASS AND I AM BOTH FROM
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO. SERVED
ON THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
TOGETHER AND- HE WAS A
REPUBLICAN I WAS A DEMOCRAT I
DON'T THINK THERE WAS A SINGLE
POLICY WE EVER AGREED ON. MOST
OF OUR CONVERSATIONS. INTO HIM
CALLING ME A REPUBLICAN AND ME
CALLING HIM A DEMOCRAT WHICH IS
OF YOU KNOW JOHN AND I YOU KNOW
HOW FUNNY THAT ACTUALLY IS- HE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THAT SPARRING ACROSS
THE AISLE. REALLY LEADS TO GOOD
IDEAS THAT WHEN WE ARE ON THE
CITY'S WE ALL SEVEN THE BUS
COULD AGREE ON A POLICY THAT IT
WAS A REALLY GOOD POLICY- HE WE
SAW HIM. AND HE WAS A. MEMBER
COMMITTEE SO SUCH AND MEMBERS
TODAY. THANK YOU MS BROWN. AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS. EVERY PLEASE
FOR THE NAMES OF THE DESERT
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO GERMAN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. IS BOERNER HORVATH
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL A GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO REQUEST
THAT WE IN TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF MAUREEN ELIZABETH CRAIG. A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE AND A
RESIDENT OF OCEANSIDE. MARINE
WAS BORN IN THE SPRING OF
NINETEEN FIFTY IN LOS ANGELES.
I GREW UP ENJOYING A HAPPY
FAMILY LIFE FOR THEIR PARENTS
AND SISTER. KATHLEEN AFTER
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SHE
ATTENDED SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ENGLISH
AND HER TEACHING CREDENTIAL. IN
THE SPRING OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO MARINE THAT DOUG CRANK A
FIRST LIEUTENANT IN THE MARINE
CORPS STATION AT CAMP
PENDLETON. THE TWO ENJOYED A
FAIRY TALE ROMANCE BEFORE
MARRYING AND WELCOMING. THEIR
TWO LOVING SONS DOUG AND ROBERT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE THE
CRAIG'S MOVED OCEANSIDE A
MARINE BROUGHT HER TEACHING
TALENTS TO BEAUMONT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL INVESTOR. LOVE FIRE
COLLEAGUES THE GIFTED EDUCATED
RETIRED FROM TEACHING IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. AFTER HAVING
ENJOYED A NEARLY FORTY YEAR
CAREER. WITH A SPECIALTY IN
READING. IN HER RETIREMENT MORE
OFFERED HER TUTORING SERVICES
TO STUDENTS AT GRACE CHURCH.
AND THE CRAIGS CONTINUED TO
TRAVEL THE WORLD TOGETHER.
MARINA BRACE THE MPORTANCE OF
AND VALUE A FAMILY UNTIL HER
LAST DAYS ENJOYING QUALITY TIME
WITH LOVED ONES INCLUDING DOUG
PATRICK ROBERT AND THERE'D HER
DAUGHTER IN LAW LEAH. MARINE
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED IN OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
DURING THE MEMORY OF MARINE
ELIZABETH CRANK. THANK YOU MS
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MEMBERS THE QUORUM
CALL REMAINS IN PLACE WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS. BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY WHILE WE AWAIT ACTION
IN THE SENATE. A BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BRO O'DONNELL
IN MYSELF AND IN HONOR OF IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH THERE
ARE GOLD COINS ON YOUR DESKS.
EIGHT YOU MAY PICK UP YOUR
COMPLIMENTARY SHAMROCK PLAN. IN
THE LOUNGE. OR CALL REMAINS IN
PLACE.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO
THE FLOOR. PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FORE FLORIDA UTILITY. WE HAVE
BUSINESS TO TAKE UP MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR.
MR CONTACT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR PROCEDURE
MOTION SIR THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER TO TAKE UP A C. R. ONE
EIGHTY NINE WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AC ARE ONE
EIGHTY NINE. COOKERY SOMETHING
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY
NINE BY FAMILY MEMBERS RENDON
AND WALDRON RELATIVE TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION OF THE LEGISLATURE. MR
SPEAKER YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS THE
PASSAGE OF THIS RESOLUTION WILL
GIVE ME NO PLEASURE BUT IT IS
NECESSARY. WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
VOTE TO RECESS THE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. IS A REQUEST TO STEP
AWAY FROM OUR DESKS MUCH
EARLIER THAN WE WOULD LIKE THE
DEMANDS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIRE IT. HOWEVER THIS IS NOT
A VACATION. THE ASSEMBLY MUST
AND WILL STAY OPEN FOR
BUSINESS. OUR WORK IS STILL
NEEDED ON OTHER ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN SQUEEZING OUR STATE.
BUT THOSE ISSUES MUST
TEMPORARILY TAKE A BACKSEAT.
OUR WORK ON CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
WORK ON HOMELESSNESS ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY AND OTHER MATTERS
CANNOT BE DROPPED ENTIRELY.
DURING THIS BREAK WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES AS WELL AS ADDRESSING
THIS CRISIS. WE'VE BEEN
DIRECTED TO CARRY ON ONLY WITH
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITIES. AS I'VE
SAID IF THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT ESSENTIAL.
THEN WE DO NOT LIVE IN A
DEMOCRACY. WE DO STILL LIVE IN
A DEMOCRACY. AND OUR WORK IS
ESSENTIAL. I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER IS WALTER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THIS
SERIOUS CRISIS REQUIRES US TO
DO THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AND IN ORDER TO
PROTECT OUR STAFF AND THE
PUBLIC. WE'VE NEEDED TO MAKE
THIS TYPE OF A CHANGE BUT AS
THE SPEAKER SAID WE'LLSTILL
KEEP WORKING WE'LL STILL KEEP
DOING THE WORK OF OUR-
CONSTITUENTS AND ANSWERING TO
THEM. AS WE GO THROUGH THIS AND
WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS CRISIS
GOES IT DOES ADD FLEXIBILITY
FOR WHEN WE CAN COME BACK. OR
IF IT IS EXTENDED- JUST
DEPENDING ON THE OUTCOME SO
TIRED AND I BOTH. THANK YOU MS
WALTER SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE
RESOLUTION WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
A ROLL CALL VOTE. ON THE
RESOLUTION CAR CLUB OF THE ROLE
RESEARCHERS ADDED ALL MEMBERS
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT. IT TAKES
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS.ALL COMMITTEE
HEARINGS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
WEEK HAVE BEEN POSTPONED. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS A
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AND MEDIA TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE ON THE H. A R.
CORRECTION A C. R.
SEEING HERE
NOW FOR THE BUSINESS. I AM
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
BONTA MOVES. AND MS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
THIRTEENTH. OR UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER. SHE WENT TO THE
PROVISIONS OF ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
EIGHTY NINE.